bonjour à tous c'est un grand plaisir
pour moi d'être là et de vous faire
cette présentation le 23 mars 2018 somme
pour moi la fin d'un déplacement
professionnel en suède 2-3 jours je dois
effectuer dans la soirée un
correspondance copenhague francfort
toulouse ce qui signifie beaucoup de
temps d'attentes à l'aéroport alors que
fait un homme comme moi quand il a un
ordinateur des téléphones et beaucoup de
temps d'attentes devant lui il
ac il teste la sécurité du système de
son choix je me présente mon nom et
bâtisses robert je suis plus connu sous
le pseudonyme d'elliot alderson le héros
de la série mr robote depuis un peu plus
d'un an je partage sur twitter à mes 100
1000 followers toutes les failles de
sécurité que je rencontre ainsi que la
manière dont vos applications et vos
téléphones volvo donner à votre insu
alors ce 23 mars 2018 je fais ce que je
fais mieux et je m'attaque à
l'application en amour l'application
donne à vendres hamoudi cet homme-là
narendra modi c'est l'actuel premier
ministre indien il a cette application
est un réel ovni dans le paysage
politique
aucun homme politique sur la planète ne
possède une application de ce type là
avec une telle audience plus de 10
millions de téléchargements sur le
plastron et un tel nombre de
fonctionnalités
alors que je trouvais cette application
vous permet de créer un profil pour
devenir membres de la communauté
vous avez déjà tous créé un profil de ce
type là lors de la création de ce profil
on va vous demander des données
personnelles très très personnelle votre
nom votre prénom votre adresse votre
numéro de téléphone
votre numéro de vote en votre caste
votre religion mais vous êtes vous déjà
demandé
où ces données vont tél une fois que
vous une fois que vous avez appuyé sur
le bouton valider à qui ces données sont
elles transmises
je suis un garçon curieux donc j'ai
essayé de répondre à ces questions et
afin de répondre à ces questions
j'ai observé les communes j'ai observé
les communications faites par le
téléphone lors de la création de ce
profil ce que j'ai rapidement observé
c'est que c'est que le téléphone faisait
des requêtes envoyées des données un
autre domaine relativement étrange im
point wd re4 point com alors pour un
chercheur en sécurité comme moi quand on
voit les noms de domaine assez étrange
comme ça on tique rapidement en faisant
un peu des recherches je me suis aperçu
que la société qui avait essayé de
cacher ses liens avec ce domaine là
s'appelle clé de retape clef verte ap
c'est une société américaine
anciennement basé en inde qui promet aux
développeurs d'applications mobiles d'
augmenter l'engagement de ses
utilisateurs grâce à une plateforme dite
d'analytique cette plateforme où on va
voir en détail on verra en détail ce
qu'est une plateforme d'analytique un
peu plus tard alors une fois que j'ai
publié mes révélations sur twitter un
torrent médiatique s'est abattue sur moi
l'opposant politique principal de
narendra modi rahul gandhi suivi par
plus de neuf millions de personnes sur
twitter publié un tweet sur le sujet
distillant un peu plus de suspicion sur
l'application les jours qui suivirent
virent une réelle crise politique en
inde les députés les parlementaires
indien posant même des questions en
séance publique sur mon identité et les
données auxquelles j'avais pu accéder
vous imaginez une bande de
parlementaires indien se demandant ce
qui est ce petit frenchy qui qui en
train de les embêter
alors au delà de ce drama de ce cinéma
dont internet a le secret quelles sont
la réalité des faits l'application
hameau utilise une solution dite
d'analytique c'est relativement
classique dans le monde du développement
mobile
voyons ce que propose la société clover
talent je suis donc allé voir la
documentation des développeurs et on
peut voir en lisant cette doc que clever
cap permet aux développeurs des pieds
tous vos faits et gestes dans les
applications
ainsi par exemple lorsque vous avez
lorsque vous allez lancer une
application un profil utilisateur va
être envoyée sur les serveurs de clés de
leur tape avec notamment la localisation
de l'utilisateur au moment où vous avez
démarrer l'application le développeur
peut également ajouter des champs les
chante son choix clever tape utilisent
les données qu'elles avec colt pour vous
profilés et pour cibler les utilisateurs
mais plus grave encore elle permet aux
développeurs de créer des campagnes
ciblées sur des groupes de personnes qui
possèdent des propriétés ou des
comportements similaires
remettons un peu les choses dans son
contexte
l'application de marennes rameau dit
l'actuel premier ministre indien le plus
grand pays du monde
un des plus grands pays du mot permet à
la possibilité grâce à une société
américaine de moduler par exemple le
contenu des news qu'elle diffuse à ses
utilisateurs en fonction de la
caractéristique de son choix
leur religion leur caste leur
localisation
nous sommes complètement dans le coeur
de métier qui était celui de cambridge
analystes 1 à 10 cas alors vous pouvez
me rétorquer
c'est en inde c'est loin tout ça nous on
est en france c'est assez loin de nous
vous trompez je suis sûr que parmi vous
il y a des vous connaissez les gens qui
possèdent des téléphones wiko par
exemple alors oui quoi c'est une marque
commerciale fondée par un fabricant de
téléphones chinois
tino en 2010 début 2014
oui qu étaient deuxièmes dans la vente
de téléphones sans abonnement en france
pour un hacker une marque a pas mal de
succès c'est une cible de choix
je me suis donc intéressé à leur
téléphone lorsque j'analyse un téléphone
mon premier réflexe est d'aller voir les
applications dites système
alors qu'est ce que c'est une
application system une application
systems
c est une application qui est déjà
installée sur votre téléphone par le
constructeur d'une part le constructeur
c'est à dire que lorsque vous allez
déballer votre téléphone dans la boîte
cette application qui la plupart du
temps n'a même pas d'icône vous ne savez
pas quelle est la est déjà installée et
la particularité est que elle possède
tous les droits
elle n'a pas besoin de vous demander
votre permission comme les autres
applications
elle est spéciale de plus vous ne pouvez
pas la désinstaller jamais
alors en regardant un des téléphones de
huy co2 applications ont sauté aux yeux
en regardant leurs codes
ces deux applications je me suis aperçu
que ces deux applications tous les mois
envoyer les données de constructeurs du
téléphone l'ia mis la localisation de
l'utilisateur et son adresse ip sur des
serveurs basés en chine
mais plus étonnant encore c'était le
mécanisme de secours mis en place par le
fabricant ch
tin oo dans le cas où l'utilisateur
n'avait pas de réseau toutes ces données
personnelles qui étaient envoyés à
l'insu de l'utilisateur était envoyé par
sms sur un numéro de téléphone basé à
shenzhen en chine
on a donc un fabricant de téléphones
chinois qui créent des marques un peu
partout en europe qui rapatrie les
données de ses utilisateurs
par millions à leur insu et tout ça ne
pose de problème à personne
alors prenons une marque 1 quelle
meilleure réputation
disons apple apple dans sa dernière
version permet à l'utilisateur
d'éteindre le wifi sur le centre de
contrôle
vous avez sûrement déjà tous vu ce
centre de contrôle lorsque vous voulez
éteindre le wifi vous allez donc appuyé
sur l'icône l'icône de huy du wifi il va
passer de bleu à blanc un utilisateur
lambda donc se dire c'est bon bon we
feel est éteint en fait si vous regardez
bien si vous ouvrez l'application
paramètres vous allez vous apercevoir
que louis est allumée vous aviez juste
déconnecté votre wifi
alors pourquoi apple trompe ses
utilisateurs de cette manière c'est
assez simple en scannant en permanence
les réseaux wifi autour de vous apple va
améliorer son système de géolocalisation
et donc son application maps
qui est d'une qualité assez médiocre
aujourd'hui est par exemple prenons un
exemple très simple tous les soirs vous
allez rendre tous les soirs de la
semaine vous allez rentrer chez vous
votre wii fier est allumée vous rentrez
chez vous votre téléphone va voir
automatiquement en wifi qui connaît le
vôtre celui de votre maison
il va donc se connecter c'est à donner
le fait que vous venez de vous connecter
à votre wifi est envoyé à apple et vous
fait ça tous les soirs de la semaine
donc entre huit heures du soir est huit
heures du matin vous êtes connecté au
même où il fit ce qui veut dire que
apple est capable d'avoir votre adresse
puisqu'il connaît votre wii fit de même
pour l'adresse de votre domicile
l'adresse de professionnels alors
qu'entre pour lutter contre ce pistage
sauvage des passionnés se sont rebellés
et ont créé une association appelée
exodus rail aussi exodus permet de
lister tous les services d'un analytique
embarqué dans une application telle que
comme on l'a vu clever table leur
plateforme donne également la liste des
permissions demandées par l'ue par une
application
il existe quatre grands types d'actes de
permission celles qui veulent nous
intéressait c les permissions dites
dangereuses
lorsqu'on vous demande lorsqu'une
application veut utiliser une permission
dites dangereuses par exemple comme
obtenir votre localisation obtenir votre
journal d'appels obtenir la liste de vos
contacts
elle est obligée d'obtenir votre
consentement
et pour l'obtenir elle va elle va vous
affichez ce pop-up
alors vous êtes prévenus la prochaine
fois que vous voyez ce pop-up
n'appuyez pas machinalement sur valider
vos peuples vous signifie que quelque
chose de grave est en train d'arriver
potentiellement votre vie privée est en
jeu potentiellement une application veut
intenter au bon fonctionnement de votre
téléphone vous allez me dire mais en
fait c'est quoi le problème là dedans
quel est le souci de donner la
localisation attin d'heure de donner mon
adresse email
lorsque je me connecte au wi fi du mcdo
c'est quoi le problème
je suis pas un criminel je n'ai rien à
cacher vous êtes sûr vous êtes sûr que
vous avez rien à cacher par exemple vous
avez tous déjà pris avec vos téléphones
portables des photos des photos de vous
des photos de votre copine des photos de
vote femme des photos intimes
savez vous sur android à chaque fois que
vous prenez une photo vos photos sont
mises en ligne sur google photos de plus
et vous l'avez accepté
google utilise vos photos afin
d'améliorer son algorithme
d'intelligence artificielle
ce qui veut dire que tous les jours
google des opérateurs des machines de
chez google accède à vos photos afin
d'améliorer d'autres produits basés sur
l'intelligence artificielle
vous avez donc payer ce service gratuit
google photos avec vos données
personnelles
prenons un autre exemple facebook
vous participez à des événements vous
aimez les pages ou fait des amis vous
rendez vous compte du nombre de données
personnelles que vous donnez à facebook
il ya des gens dont c'est le métier des
datas scientist qui sont là pour
collecter exploiter ces données et
dresser un profil très précis de qui
vous êtes
ce profil est ensuite utilisée pour
améliorer leur outil de publicité
cet outil de publicité très très très
très performant
par exemple lorsque vous les diffuser
une publicité sur facebook vous pouvez
cibler toutes les personnes entre 18 et
24 ans résidant sur lyon et faisant des
études d'ingénieur c'est cet outil
extraordinaire extraordinairement précis
qui a permis un certain donald trump
entre autres de devenir président des
états unis
donc on voit la force la force de vos
données personnelles et l'importance que
vos données personnelles nom sur sur le
monde d'aujourd'hui
alors j'ai une dernière question pour
vous pourquoi de nombreuses applications
de nombreux sites vous demande votre
numéro de téléphone
et ne vous appelle jamais ils n'ont leur
business et même pas relié au téléphone
jamais il ne vous appellerons mais
pourquoi il vous le demande car vous ne
changez jamais c'est donc un identifiant
constant sur votre personne ainsi quand
des data broker donc des gens qui
achètent des bases de données des
hackers vont recoupé des bases de
données entre elles vont connecter des
bases de données entre elles grâce à cet
identifiant constants on va pouvoir
mettre ensemble connecter toutes les
informations qu'on pose est-ce qu'on
peut qu'on possède sur vous et ainsi
dressé un profil très précis de qui vous
êtes
ainsi vous avez donné un élément un site
un élément à notre site un élément un
troisième site et tout ça au final est
récupérée collecter connectés afin
d'obtenir une image très précise de qui
vous êtes
alors pour finir je vais pas vous
laisser comme ça
comment on peut se protéger alors c'est
très simple
en réalité il faut juste se poser les
bonnes questions quand vous allez sur le
plastron sur l'app store que vous
téléchargez une application gratuite
posez vous cette question très simple
l'application est gratuite mais derrière
il y avait un propriétaire il ya des
développeurs qui ont travaillé pendant
des semaines pendant des mois un
développeur comme moi ça coûte ça coûte
cher alors comment ils font pour manger
tous les jours ces gens là comment ils
gagnent de l'argent vous en doutez un
petit peu maintenant la réponse c'est
qu'ils se payent avec vos données
personnelles
ils vont récolter vos données
personnelles parfois les partager à des
tiers à des sociétés tierces afin
d'obtenir un minimum d'argent c'est
relativement courant dans le monde des
start-up parts donc pour éviter pour
éviter ce phénomène
votre premier réflexe avant de
télécharger une application afin
d'utiliser ou avant de donner des
données personnelles doit être de lire
les conditions générales d'une
application d'un site
ça va vous permettre de répondre à des
questions générales quelques quelles
sont les données personnelles que me
demande ce service qu'elles sont
comment la société justifie de me
prendre ses données personnelles
est ce que mes données les données que
je vais données sont partagées à des
sociétés tierces
et pour finir je voudrais vous laisser
je voudrais vous partager ce message
lorsque vous partager quelque chose sur
internet lorsque vous mettez une donnée
sur internet
elle ne vous appartient plus ainsi posez
vous la question êtes vous prêt à
échanger votre vie privée
vos données personnelles en échange de
services gratuits
merci
[Applaudissements]